we've talked about this before but you
love golf can you play golf now I would
think that would be one of the sports
you could play absolutely right it's one
of the few things that you know you
could stay socially distanced and you're
outside and you're in the elements and
the winds blowing the sun's out and you
know yeah I've been keeping that up so
that's been nice to do to see the same
you know five people around this period
of time everybody's been tested we've
all like you know gotten the negative
results so it's cool to be out and it's
the same dudes that I played with a lot
you know it's Anthony Anderson and
George Lopez and Cedric the Entertainer
and Chris Spencer and DL Hughley so we
all keep going
that's a fun group that's a really fun
group yeah we just we just laugh and
laugh and laugh and laugh a lot oh yeah
the celebrities I hang with are the
original kids from menudo that's all
yeah they're all in there they're all
late I would say late 50s early 60s now
yeah but they feel probably like they're
70 because if they have so much row done
and yeah yes and they don't get but the
only celebrities that will hang with me
so amen you got you gotta love your
friends right Anthony Anderson has been
telling people that you like to play for
sort of interesting you like to wager
when you play golf and it can get
interesting we we have had sort of a
running first we had a brownie Cup which
we used to play at Pebble Beach and then
we moved it around and then because
there was such demand to get in the cup
we had to open it up and create the
brownie Invitational which was much more
relaxed than the rules as far as who
could be a member so we actually just
had another brownie event last month DL
Hughley won he is the reigning champion
of the brownie Invitational so is use
the winner get a certain brownie no
that's not that's not the prize the
winner actually gets a trophy which is a
beautiful trophy that George purchased a
beautiful trophy no the brownie aspect
of it is
a melanin um component as well as
something that must be eaten at the
ninth at the ninth hole which makes the
back nine
very interesting is it a weed brownie is
that what you're saying you know I've
never say we don't have a lab out there
I can't say for sure what's in the
brownie I'm not a forensics expert or
anything like that I will say that it
doesn't taste like your traditional
brownie and there are flecks of some
material in it that I just can't
identify but it does make the last nine
holes really interesting it's probably
oregano you know it does have a very
oregano a su song to it so that's what
I'm gonna say it is well I hope I didn't
ruin everything for you
hey someday I'll bring the menudo crew
over we can play with you that would be
great yeah they're really God they hate
each other I stick with the original
menudo I stick with the original guys
that's me and yeah you know that's who I
am that's how I roll all right burn out
your hair we told the whole story I
gotta do something look at that can I
just stay for a second though I mean I
know people say it all the time but damn
it that's impressive man thank you
see it it's getting hold of a man are
you that you can still grow that Mane
like anyone tuning in right now I don't
know man I don't know what's going on
anymore we're all losing our minds but I
have to say you put a smile on my face I
always love talking to you I'm a very
big admirer of yours and so it lifts my
spirits to get to chat with you and I
thanks for hanging with me you know love
it
any time Cohen great to see you all any
time really well
what am I gonna say you're gonna show
this to people you know I'll take a
chinois and you'll know how okay I'm
coming by tonight with my protective
[Laughter]
he's gone damn it
all episodes of Black Monday which is
fantastic are available on Showtime and
Don's new series don't look deeper we'll
be streaming on kwibi on July 27th make
sure you check that out
Don always a pleasure seriously and
thank you thank you for hanging with me
appreciate you man thanks coming let's
do it again okay take care